hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
David hume's inquiry concerning human
understanding is going to finish in
section 12 titled of the academic or
skeptical philosophy and there's two
terms already being used there somewhat
synonymously so we've got skeptical
right and David Hume is a sort of
mitigated or as he's going to call it
academic skeptic of sorts and so we've
got academic as a kind of skepticism
he's already discussed in that section
Descartes rather hyperbolic type of
skepticism and said well it's kind of a
non-starter if we take it seriously but
it can be useful in parts and now he's
going to bring up another term pyronian
skepticism and he's going to contrast
pyronian against academic or academical
right
and historically there is kind of a
distinction right the academic
skepticism is arising within Plato's
Academy as they turn away from the
original platonism to a rather skeptical
uh way of approaching things and they
contrast themselves against the
dogmatist what we should point out is
that there is a sort of Hardcore
skepticism and then a probabilistic or
mitigated skepticism even within Plato's
Academy and then we've got this guy pyro
who's outside of the academy indeed
outside of the socratic tradition which
runs through so many other things pyro
was himself a person who taught
skepticism and we're going to see other
later Skeptics like sexist empiricus
taking up the pyronian point of view and
so in any case these are terms that
humans using that have some resonance to
his audience who are familiar with the
history of ideas
now the first thing he's actually going
to consider is kind of outside of these
distinctions and this is at the very
beginning of part two he is going to
talk about this Chief objection against
all abstract reasonings derived from the
ideas of space and time and so he says
these are ideas which in common life
into a careless view are very clear and
intelligible right so we're used to
working in space and time we don't even
need to really think about it like I'm
moving in space and existing in time
right now
but there are some things that are going
to arise from philosophizing or applying
reason to thinking about these sorts of
manners he says when they pass through
the scrutiny of the profound sciences
and they're the chief object of these
Sciences they afford principles which
seem full of absurdity and contradict
action so what what Sciences is he
talking about
arithmetic uh geometry he's also
thinking perhaps about physics to some
degree insofar as it's uh working from
you know ideas abstracted away from the
the reality of space and time that we
experience so he goes out and he talks
about geometricins and metaphysicians
right and he talks about
something that really bothers him and
quite a few other people of his time I
don't know that we're quite so bothered
by this in the present as Hume takes all
of his readers to be but let's see where
he goes so he tells us
no Priestly dogmas have ever shocked
Common Sense more than the doctrine of
the infinite divisibility of extension
so extension space and of course time
things that can be measured with their
consequences a real quantity infinitely
less than any finite quantity containing
qualities infinitely less than itself
and so on in infinitum this is an
edificial bold and prodigious it is too
weighty for any pretended demonstration
to support because it shocks the
clearest and most natural principles of
human reason and then he says it gets
worse so how does it get worse what
renders the matter more extraordinary he
tells us is that these seemingly absurd
opinions are supported by a chain of
reasoning the clearest and more natural
nor is it possible to allow the premises
without admitting the consequences and
he'll contrast the arguments about the
infinite divisibility of space and time
which by the way I mean the integral
calculus which people are now using a
lot invented both by Newton and by
leibniz
um it's been around for a while and you
know people are
instrumentalizing it but the theory of
it is From hume's perspective kind of
hinky so you've got that sort of stuff
over here and then we've got all these
other reasonings about geometric matters
right that seem perfectly clear as a
matter of fact geometry and math for a
very long time were used as like the
examples of things that are you know as
what humans going to call relations of
ideas and we can definitely know about
them because they're essentially
abstractions
now they kind of come together as he
says if we think about a case like this
how can we deny that the angle of
contact between a circle and its tangent
a line that's actually hitting it is
infinitely less than any rectilineal
angle that as you may increase the
diameter of the circle in infinitum this
angle of contact becomes still less and
the angle of contact between other
curves and their tangents may be
infinitely less so on in infinitum right
and he says the demonstration of these
principles so using reason to
demonstrate it seems as unexceptionable
as that which proves three angles of a
triangle to be equal to two right ones
even though the latter opinion be
natural and easy the other big with
contradiction and absurdity
so he tells us that reason itself is
thrown into a kind of amazement and he
says you know
um we can do this as well with with time
an infinite number of real parts of time
passing in succession exhausted one
after another appears so evident a
contradiction that we wouldn't want to
admit and yet we're stuck with these he
says how any clear distinct idea can
contain circumstances contradictory to
itself or to any other clear distinct
idea is incomprehensible and as perhaps
as absurd in a proposition as can be
formed and then he says okay so this
actually gets us kind of off the hook
the skepticism itself is skeptical we
can't even make sense out of that he
says nothing can be more skeptical or
full of doubt and hesitation than this
skepticism itself which arises from the
paradoxical conclusions of John geometry
or the science of quality and that's all
he's going to say about that so
skepticism we sort of if we're engaging
in reasoning about these matters
infinite divisibility of space and time
or extension we're going to arrive in a
kind of skepticism but then we can also
be skeptical of that very skepticism and
how we wound up there so we're going to
put that aside what about what he calls
moral evidence or rather when we see the
word moral we tend to think in terms of
Ethics this is broader any matter of
fact anything that involves experience
he says that
we can divide the skeptical objections
to moral evidence or the reasonings
concerning matter of fact into two types
popular and philosophical so the popular
objections he says these come from uh
the natural weakness of the human
understanding contradictory opinions
which have been entertained in different
ages and Nations variations of our
judgment and sickness and health Youth
and old age prosperity and adversity the
Perpetual contradiction of each
particular man's opinions and sentiments
with many other topics of that kind so
this is sort of like the standard you
know take or fodder of skepticism
throughout the ages right this is
popular stuff Hume actually considers
these objections to be rather weak and
to be you know essentially defeated by
looking at common life he says in common
life we reason every moment concerning
fact and existence and we can't possibly
assist without continually employing the
species of argument so any popular
objections derived from that must be
insufficient to destroy the evidence the
great subverter of pyrionism he's saying
here is or the excessive principles of
skepticism is action employment and the
occupations of common life we can
pretend to be skeptical but we can't
really be skeptical because we we do
things and that skepticism in in this
pyronian sense goes out the window once
we're actually engaged in things so
popular we're going to put that aside
what about philosophical skepticism
here Hume is actually going to refer us
to his own doctrines that he's been
developing within this work he says the
skeptic should keep within his proper
sphere and use philosophical objections
which arise from more profound
researches and Hume says well here he's
got a better basis right he insists all
our evidence for any matter of fact
which lies beyond the testimony of
sensor memory is derived entirely from
the relation of cause and effect okay
that's a human principle right right
there right and what about this cause
and effect he says we have no idea of
this relation than that of two objects
which have been frequently conjoined
together we have no argument to convince
us objects which have in our experience
been frequently conjoined will likewise
in other instances be conjoined in the
same manner nothing leads us to this
inference but custom or a certain
Instinct of our nature which may be
difficult to resist but like other
instincts may be fallacious and
deceitful this is hume's own teaching
right his own position and so he says if
a skeptic insists on these topics he
shows his force or rather indeed his own
and our weakness and he seems to be
destroying any sort of conviction right
so we could look at this in a pyronian
or excessive way Hume says and here he
tells us that that's not going to work
for kind of similar reasons as he's
attacking the popular he says that no
durable good can ever result from it
while it remains in its full force and
vigor what does that mean so we we can
think of philosophical doctrines as
serving some sort of purpose and we can
actually ask as he does here
uh what his meaning is what he proposes
by all these curious researchers what is
the skeptic really after and here Hume
is going to use some examples of people
who are not Skeptics but rather what
Skeptics would call dogmatists so a
copernican or ptolemaic this is in
astronomy each of them has their own way
of looking at it big controversy in the
early modern age right both of them want
to figure things out about how the
heavens work right he hopes to produce a
conviction which will remain constant
and durable with his audience in moral
life a stoic or Epicurean displays
principles which may not only be durable
but also have an effect on conduct and
behavior that tell us how we ought to
live they give us guidance in the
activities of what humans calling common
life
what about a pyronian Hume says a
pyronian cannot expect his philosophy
will have any constant influence on the
mind or if it had its influence would be
beneficial to Society on the contrary he
must acknowledge if he will acknowledge
anything all human life must perish if
his principles universally and steadily
were to Prevail all discourse all action
would immediately cease and Men remain
in a total lethargy till the necessities
of nature put an end to their miserable
existence I mean that's one way of
thinking about it we could also think
about pyro himself who according to the
stories about him had to have handlers
because he would walk off a cliff
otherwise saying well I don't know if
I'm going to die if I walk off this
Cliff so you know on the one hand we
could be like total in action or we
could have arbitrary and unfounded uh
and dangerous action as well now he does
say though pyronian skepticism you know
I can hold for a little while it can can
throw oneself and others into a kind of
temporary confusion
but it's not lasting so that kind of
skepticism is too much
it defeats itself
Hume is actually against pyronian
skepticism what about what he's calling
mitigated or academical skepticism well
Hume is actually a fan of that right he
it's interesting too because he says at
a later point this is a small tincture
of pyrionism so it's not as if there's
like a dividing line academic or
mitigated skepticism on this side
pyronian skepticism on this side it's
it's really more of a Continuum right
you have you know going too far pyronian
skepticism you can have a tincture of it
so it's a tincture of that very same
excessive skepticism so
um what can we do with that
he tells us this can actually be quite
helpful for uh two main reasons so he
says that there's you know the majority
of humankind are affirmative and
dogmatical in their opinions and they
throw themselves precipitously into the
principles to which they're inclined and
they don't have any Indulgence for those
who entertain opposite sentiments
they're sort of arbitrarily committed to
things and they think that they know
more than they do and this is where
skepticism can actually be quite
valuable it erodes that he says
um
could such dogmatical reasoners become
sensible of the strange infirmities of
human understanding right and this
reflection would naturally Inspire them
with more modesty and reserve and
diminish their fond opinion of
themselves and their prejudice against
antagonists right so it'll not only help
them
not necessarily make their way to truth
but not fall into falsity quite so much
they also won't be so
you know prone to reject other people's
ideas so that's a good thing right so
that's a useful thing and could apply
even to philosophers and then Hume goes
on further and says that there's another
species of mitigated skepticism which
may be of advantage to Mankind and which
may be the natural result of the
pyronian doubts and scruples
the limitation of our inquiries to such
subjects as are best adapted to the
narrow capacity of the human
understanding so we restrict ourselves
in our studies in our arguments and our
inquiries to what it is that we actually
can make some genuine progress in that
is the ordinary course of human life
he says the imagination of a human being
is naturally Sublime running without
control into the most distant parts of
space and time into in order to avoid
the objects which custom has rendered to
familiar to it let's not do that if
we're skeptical let's say well maybe we
don't indulge our imagination quite so
much and we stick to the things where we
can actually make some genuine progress
and that would be a fruit of just the
right amount of pyronian skepticism
resulting in mitigated or academic
skepticism so we can see Hume is
actually a big supporter of skepticism
provided it's the right amount not to
excessive not going the whole pyronian
path but rather what he's viewing as
academic skepticism and he thinks this
could actually be quite helpful for us
as human beings things